Oh my god!
Spooky!
Happy Halloween!
You guys probably don't know any of these songs, well maybe some of them, but I'll do my best.
To my stream!
Thank you!
準備運動しよう 中に内装 柔軟 君への想いを 鍛えてるです あの日の失敗 取り戻せ 君の通路 往復して 行き出して 告白した私 パチで振った君に I try to act tough, but it's just a one-sided fight.
I love you.
Even if you turn your back on me, I'm a zombie.
You're the only one I have in place of you.
I can't even cheat on you.
See, I'm always chasing you with a dash.
Don't be attracted to me.
Even if I put on make-up, my heart is pure.
No matter how many times I do it, I'm still a zombie.
I love you.
After all, I have no choice but to love you.
The truth is...
Turn the wheel of fate a little more.
No matter how many times I do it, I'm still a zombie.
I love you.
Zombie Bridge, let's cross it.
Let's cross it, let's cross it.
Kyou mo kimi wo mezashite
ZON ZON ZOMBINA
Z -O-M-B-I
Itsuka shinu hodo warareru deshou?
Datte eikyuu ni kumetsu nara
aeru ZOMBINA Koi wa shindemo shinanai nai ZOMBINA Hora ne doki doki darake dekiru no shibarashi Suki desu itsumademo Eikyuu fumetsu tamashii de Everyday I love you ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON ZON The
next song!
Hai!
Se-no!
Kyouhou tsukkei!
Kansen shoubin chokyo!
ZAZA!
MAIBA!
Amakute kowai sekai e welcome Sutekina yume ga miremasu you ni Kakurete naide ofesukora Hyakunenburi no dokidokita wa SAIGA!
SAIGA!
MAIBA!
Himitsu no makari ga to Mangetsu no akari ni terasarete Taikutsu wa oshimai Yamiyo no kabocha ga warau Ikutsu monokage ni kakomare Hitoban no ohimesama Fushigi no box aketara Mou tamaranai yo Otona mo kodomo mo Minna odoreki no ribbon hodoite Watashitachi ni tsuite oide yo Yozora wo koete daikakukai!
Zen ni mo noboru itazura wo Omimai shichau kono yoru ni Let's check our G!
Machi chuu wa ima mo Ra-ta-ta-ta party!
Sa!
Naku kodomaru wa itazura wo Otodoke shichau kono yoru ni So, tick-tack!
Tokei mo odoru wa asa made Showtime!
Amakute kowai sekai e Welcome!
Gokigen mama ga Give a tip!
Te yonde!
Kyou no kimete wa Cool!
Niko!
Chic!
Hyakunenbori no Wakuwakutawa!
Sora!
Ni!
Jizo!
Sei!
Tara!
Hiji!
Nozeri!
Anochi!
Rokatte!
Kuro neko no osasoi Kangei no kyandoru wo tootte Ibutsu na tomodachi ni Omocha no gita wo prezentou Zenrigan no megane mo Kakete mokuteki wa Oujisama!
Fushigi no boxu Aketara mou Tomaranai yo!
Obake mo bento mo Minna teji na omiyage wo kakaete Himei no naka de Juggling sa!
Yozora wo koete Daikatsui!
Kokoro ni hibiku Itazura wo Kitai sasechau Kono yoru ni Let's shake our cheeks!
Hoshikuzu mo zutto Ra-ta-ta-ta Party sa!
Hitoaji chigau Itazura wo Ajiwabasechau Kono yoru ni So, pumpkin pun!
Mahou wo kakete Asa made show time!
Anata
to watashi mo Kyou wa itsumo no kamen wo nugisutte Saigo no kissu de Ichikoro yo Yozora wo koete Daikatsui!
Itazura kara no romansu ni Shitate akechau Kono yoru ni Let's shake our cheeks!
Party wa mou Sorosoro Ohirai sa!
Kono yoru dake no itazura to Owakarashichau Tsugi no asa ni Oh, chocolate time!
Kore de owari nano Suteki na show time!
So, ding-dong-dang-dang Owari no kane ga Kikoeru deshou
Maybe you guys have never heard that mix before!
But that was the Deer Stage Mix!
Woo!
Okay, I'm really sorry for this next one.
Actually, I didn't practice this at all, this next one.
So, I have to kind of rush because I want to get through all my songs.
Um...
Uh...
Let's try...
Oh, I'm really sorry for this one.
You guys can hate me after this, it's okay.
Ew!
Oh my god, what is this?
What are these sound effects?
Oh my gosh, I'm really nervous about this one.
Okay, I'm not even gonna look at the chat.
I was edging to a gyaat late last night When my eyes beheld a skibbity sight Where the true Sigma Rizzler began to rise And violently mogged the Costco guy He did the mash He rizzed the bops and gyaats The monster mash Gave him a smash or a pass He did the mash He put the fries in the bag He did the mash He rizzed up all the gyaats From the back rooms in the Ohio streets Where the wolf inside me is at last at least The gooners all jelked to grow their jodes To get tips from me cause I'm a Luke's max prize He did the mash He rizzed up all the gyaats The monster mash Gave him a smash or a pass They put the fries in the bag.
He rizzed up all the gas.
The streamers were all doing the gritty.
Maybe Gronk just rizzed up Livi.
I don't know who any of these people are.
TheRizzlerBot, BigJustice, AidenRoss, and Kai...
I can't do this anymore.
I'm so excited.
Oh,
it's DanceAndDrake.
Surprise!
They rizzed up all the gas.
Gave them a smash or a pass.
They put the fries in the bag.
He rizzed up all the gas.
Pausing his stream meant Phantom did yap.
Seems like Doki Bird was about to cap.
Looked around to see if there was enough movement and said...
Did you guys know the low taper meme is still massive?
He rizzed up all the gas.
Gave them a smash or a pass.
They put the fries in the bag.
He rizzed up all the gas.
Everybody loves Skippity.
He's our ultimate Giga Chat.
And my brainwrap bash is the hit of the land.
For you, the beta, this bash was meant to...
The funniest meme ever is Haktua.
He rizzed up all the gas.
Gave them a smash or a pass.
They put the fries in the bag.
He rizzed up all the gas.
Got good.
Easy, Motara, you sussy Ohio.
Easy, Motara.
Got good.
I'm so sorry.
Anyway...
Wait, why is it only just one ear?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on you guys.
Oh no!
There's scuff!
Wait, there can't be scuff!
I don't have time for scuff!
Wait, hold on.
Oh shoot!
Oh my gosh, how do I get to my folders?
Hold on.
Um...
I might just have to skip a song.
No, I was gonna do Busted, but then why is it so...
Guys, I don't know how to get to my fol...
Oh, I know how to get to my folders!
Hold on.
I think I have it.
This is so...
Okay, it's just gonna be in one ear.
Why is it so...
Wait, I can fix this.
I think.
How do I fix this?
Nah, it's just gonna be in one ear.
This is so bad.
Guys, it's just in my right ear right now.
Why is it in just one ear?
Singular Busted...
I don't know why.
If there's something strange, sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
If there's something weird, sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Busted makes me feel good.
I don't know why.
It's just in the right ear.
Busted, Busted, Busted...
Busted!
Oh my god.
If you're seeing things, sleeping in your bed.
Sleeping in your bed.
Ow!
Let me tell you something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Busted.
Busted!
Feel good!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Breaking Ghost Man!
Breaking Man, baby!
Snoring.
Let me tell you something.
Sleepin' makes me feel good!
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
Yeah,
yeah.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bustin', bustin', bustin' makes me feel in
the right gear.
I'm sorry.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin'.
I don't know the problem.
I'm sorry.
Bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin', bustin' makes me feel good.
Yeah, baby!
You might have thought that might be my last song, but I have one last song.
Everybody, oh my gosh, I hope you've been enjoying the relay so far.
Everybody has sounded so amazing.
And Ashiki was right before me.
She sounded incredible.
Thank you, Spectra and Maria for hosting it.
And after me, I believe is Pippa.
Cute penguin.
Thank you for joining us.
Thanks for having me.
So, yeah, one last song.
It's a TV size though, because I don't think I could sing the whole one.
And also, I don't remember the middle of it.
So, and I'm also in a lot of pain.
Oh, what just happened there?
Weird.
You guys know this one, maybe?
The most zombie song.
Well, not the most.
I'm a zombie today.
Did you notice?
And I have a zombie set list, mostly.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Enjoy the rest of the relay.
This is Mii Phantom.
Bye-bye.
Or this was Mii Phantom.
Anyway, bye.
Bye.
Wait, how do I stop the song?
Oh, hold on.
Fade out.